[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to another
episode of real estate the Ramsey Way
the housing market has uh seen some
pretty weird times lately and while
things aren't as crazy as they were just
a couple of years ago it's still not a
Walkin the park out there interest rates
are up prices while steady are also high
and there just aren't enough homes for
sale bottom line is you really need to
be informed on what's happening in the
market and how it affects you so stick
around and listen to my conversations
with folks struggling with things like
affordability and refinancing in this
unusual Market Caitlyn joins us up next
she's in Arizona Caitlyn welcome to the
show hello how are you good how can we
help
today yeah I just had a quick question
in regards to overcoming a negative
mindset so I'm 29 I live out in Arizona
I'm a single mom and as you know our
housing market has been gelle intense to
say at least um and I'm paying about 60%
of my take-home paying rent I yeah I
can't buy in this market I don't make
enough I pulled down to about 40 last
year um and I just feel like I'm
spinning my wheels and that Treading
Water feeling is really starting to get
to me so I was hoping you could provide
some insight on that if possible yeah I
mean I I'll be honest Kaitlin I'm like I
I would feel that too if if more than
half the paycheck is going to housing
that's a that's a big chunk so tell me
uh a little bit more about kind of the
situation because you are obviously in
an a more expensive I don't know if it's
an area or apartment or what it is is
there other options for you to to change
locations just to at least catch your
breath and bring it down to at least you
know we recommend 25 30% but even if it
went down to 35% that would change your
world right yeah um I live in a
two-bedroom apartment right now um and I
pay about 2,000 a month I had looked at
going down to a one-bedroom the only
trouble with that it was it would only
Save Me Maybe 300 bucks a month but I
actually work from home um so I need and
I have my son here with me too so I
don't know how we would make that work
yeah no to B yeah yeah yeah I oh sorry I
was going to just say have you have you
driven you know 20 miles either
direction of where you currently are
just to see other
prices uh right now I'm already kind of
on the edge of um
what I would consider to be a safe area
um so I can look maybe a little bit
deeper into Phoenix but I just want to
make sure we're still safe and
everything's good like that so um I I
could I mean I I work remotely so I
could probably Buy in other states and
other markets but my son's father's here
and I really just don't want to leave um
my home state so for sure for sure
understandable and how much do you make
a
year I pulled down about 40 uh last year
okay what are you doing for work
uh I work at a call center for an
insurance company
okay so there's there's only two ways we
can go about this and we can we can
spend less and we can make more so do
you have any payments in your life that
we can get rid of do you have any
debt I don't have any debt um I do have
that going for me I don't have any debt
and I do um anticipate my income going
up um actually I had a conversation
yesterday with my supervisor that made
me feel like maybe something close is on
the horizon
um for getting my my pay up um I think
it's just this waiting period between uh
making more money and trying to find
something cheaper to to rent it's just
it's mentally been draining me I think
but um well especially as a single mom I
mean you're you got your how old your
how old's your
son he just turned six his name is Mason
I think he might be listening that's
awesome hi that's awesome oh well you're
doing an incredible job Caitlyn I mean
you know the the hard thing is it's
nothing that you're doing wrong it's
just that the numbers are kind of
stacked against you and so like George
said you know an option of bringing in
more I mean right now the job market is
just insane and so I would push and look
to see if you can even I mean 40 Grand
you know you're you're you're doing fine
but man people are paying just insane
amounts of money right now for jobs and
and since your is not like very
specifically specialized you know what I
mean like I feel like you could um do
all sorts of things uh even with the
experience that you've had in this
insurance role um so you know I don't
know if it's looking for something else
or a different apartment but one of
those two things really probably it
needs to shift for your own sanity
Caitlin you know what I mean like
temporarily yeah to have the numbers
work for you um is going to be a big
deal do you have an emergency fund
Caitlyn I do yeah okay three to six
months in
there uh I still have my baby one I have
a a $11,000 emergency fund and then I
have about 4,000 000 in my my actual uh
emergency fund so I still need to build
that up okay I think building that up
may help with a little bit of that
Financial Peace and anxiety about what
if something happens if one check
doesn't come in what are we going to do
and if you get that in place then I'm
going to start saving up for a house
slowly and I know it's hard because
there's not a lot of margin right now
but that feels like it's the long-term
goal and I'm hoping that all this
craziness is not forever and so a year
from now hopefully we're looking at a
very different picture and you are work
from home and so that does open you up
but I know you've got to will stay close
to home because of the uh situation with
your son and so there's not a ton of
options here other than let's look at
the budget let's do a budget audit where
can we save every single insurance
premium every single expense I'm going
through that with a fine Toth comb going
how can I shave off 10 bucks 20 bucks 30
bucks yeah absolutely and then the
income I mean the yeah income and
apartment um situations would change too
you know yeah but you're doing a great
job kayin you really are you're doing a
great job for for where you're at um
incredible no debt you have savings I
mean all of it you really are but that
60% it oh that that hurts me it's a
tough situation and this inflation stuff
I mean it's hitting people all over
their pocketbooks from rent to gas to
food and so there's just batting down
the hatches and let's get to work let's
get the second job if we have to Let's
trim the subscriptions that we're not
using right now and all the little
luxuries that we once enjoyed might need
to go away temporarily yeah for a season
because they're saying you know I I read
a report and they think in the next 18
months with just even the um the supply
chain all of that but I'm like I mean
the hard thing is after two years I've
just learned who knows like who knows
that's right I remember April of 2020
doing Instagram lives I did one like
every other day just to answer questions
and I I said I guys I think by August
all this this will all be over it's all
going to be over here we are so I'm not
predicting anything but uh I think you
just have to prepare with where we're at
the reality of what's going on and what
and what sucks is that that means
cutting back some because the numbers
everything is going up yeah and if
you're single you don't have kids
there's more options because we can go
all right let's get you a roommate now
it's more difficult when you have a
family when you've got kids involved
it's not that simple right but if you
work from home that can open you up to a
lot of options too you may not want to
live on the outskirts of town but
temporarily for a year if we have to
sign that lease to go all right we can
now breathe and still hit our other
financial goals I'm okay with that and
it's amazing what peace of mind even
does right like we can talk about the
numbers and the percentages and all of
that all day long but there is just
something to be said about when you do
have margin it gives you a level of
Peace like a level of like you can take
a breath and sometimes it's worth s the
things you never thought you would do I
never would live this far from wherever
right people make these claims and then
when Life Starts hitting you and you
think okay is it now I would rather live
far farther away yeah and actually have
peace of mind and margin and enjoy life
a little bit more than everything just
getting sucked out of the paycheck so
much out of our control too and so I
always like to go what is in my control
so in Caitlyn's situation if I'm anyone
listening right now I'm going all right
let me make a list of ways I can make
more and ways I can spend less I'm going
to make a list of five things and I'm
GNA go okay which one can I go do this
week this month and just start trying
things what can I sell on Facebook
Marketplace that's been sitting in the
closet for a while what is that second
job I can take for a few months to just
supplement my income temporarily yeah
and so if you start doing all that and
that's why I love the budget audit it's
kind of a real nerdy thing but you go
man I'm way overpaying for auto
insurance let me connect with Xander and
oh my gosh I just saved 100 bucks right
there and you start doing that in all
areas we've talked about this on your
show Rachel with cable and internet and
yeah how can we start shaving all this
down our phone bills to where now we
have 200 bucks a month yes in margin we
can breathe a little bit and it's not
easy I'm not trying to make it sound
like it's just but it's the stuff that's
the kind of the auto the autodraft the
auto pay where you're just like oh and
then you look up two years you're like
wow I've never pushed on that or seen
that you know what I mean and and doing
that it does it gives you gives you some
more margin yeah you got to advocate for
yourself and get yourself in a better
financial position and that's why our
plan works in good times and bad I mean
imagine if she had all these debt
payments looming in her life y great
work Caitlyn you done a great job good
job Tanner's with us in Washington DC hi
Tanner how are
you I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's
up so my question is I'm curious about
the flexib of spending more than 30% of
your takh home pay on rent found that
pretty difficult to do especially in
like an urban area like DC I live in
downtown um I make around 990,000 a year
post grad 23y old um I got about 20,000
in cash and 7,000 uh in an investment
account and M myly debt is around seven
7 and a half th000 in student loans and
I spend about $2,000 a month in rent
which is my biggest expense expense by
far but I still find myself able to save
um and spend less on other things I'm
just curious your take on on that
approach okay well we tell folks to put
25% of their take home pay aside for
housing and uh no math Works in every
city and in every state you don't get a
pass on math because you're in
Washington DC even though Congress
thinks you do I was getting ready to say
a lot of people think they do yeah a lot
of people in DC think you do but you
don't and the the purpose behind it is
not that 25% is Magic Tanner uh the
purpose behind it is don't be house poor
if you find yourself able to save and uh
able to invest because you keep all
other parts of your lifestyle so low
then then you're okay but if you're you
but what happens to most people is when
they've got a high cost of housing in
their budget it squeezes their budget
and there's not room to uh save up to
buy the next car so the next car becomes
debt and there's not room to save up for
for Christmas and Christmas becomes debt
and there's not room to save up for a
couch and the couch becomes debt and
because it's all going out in house
payment and so in effect what you did is
you uh you you you didn't you know by by
squeezing yourself you did that now
you're telling me you've made room in
your budget and you're doing okay then
you know if whatever you want to do
brother but here's the thing whatever
you spend on rent is
gone mhm I mean you're just setting fire
to $100 bills in the middle of the floor
and so the more $100 bills you burn in
the middle of the floor the fewer M less
money you got man I mean it's a pretty
simple
equation yeah yeah definitely definitely
reduces the ability to buy down the road
for sure yeah yeah I mean because you're
giving it to them in rent and so I don't
know how you fix that exactly
necessarily in your situation maybe
you're commute is longer maybe there's a
roommate involved or uh or maybe you
just say I'm going to it's going to cost
cost me this and it's my choice and I'm
an adult well yeah you're allowed to do
all that but our reason to give you
giving you the 25% guideline it's not a
rule it's a guideline is so that you
don't become house poor because if
you're for instance going to get a
mortgage folks in America um the stupid
mortgage company will approve you for
almost double
that I mean they'll approve you close to
50% of your take home pay 36% of your uh
ratio you know and so and that's not
based on take home pay the 36 that you
can get a house payment up close to half
of your dadgum take home pay and there's
just no way that budget Works people and
well I'm in California well California
they got to do math too even though your
Governor doesn't think so you got to do
math you know it's not it's not an
option math is math and it's not it's
not a a a moral construct it's a it's a
math thing well to win Tanner in
professional World Financial World
you've got to sacrifice everybody who
wins has to sacrifice something and what
we've done here with this 25% you are
now having to choose do you want to
sacrifice money as Dave said by by
burning those extra100 between the 5%
that we're talking about or do you want
to sacrifice a little bit of your time
now you're live in downtown DC that's
premium and I get it you may work on the
hill who knows what you do but you're
there for a reason but if you move out
into the suburbs of Northern Virginia I
know it well yes it's a it's a headache
uh but we'd rather you sacrifice the
right thing and that's why we put this I
want people to understand what we're
teaching here it's not to be hard and
fast on a rule it's to help you learn
what you need to sacrifice and in my
situation if I were in your situation
Tanner I would be sacrificing my time
not my money yeah 23 years old yeah yeah
you know I will tell you this Ken I did
it worse than he's doing it sure worse
yeah he's in good my wife and I get
out of college and here's how stupid we
were we go and rent a we we have two
dogs we're just out of College we got
two little
jobs we go and rent a
three-bedroom townhouse sure luxury
right thing sure that's like five times
what we needed MH because we thought it
was cool do you remember what were in
the extra rooms uh
nothing sure cuz by the time we finished
paying the freaking rent we had no money
yeah yeah so what we ended up doing was
moving into a little one-bedroom uh
apartment and a questionable
uh I don't know what those ladies down
the hall were doing in a questionable
situation and um you were hoping you
weren't on a Vice episode man I'm
telling you and uh we lived there for a
year but it was
one3 the rent that we were paying before
onethird and so that'd be like you you
had an $1,800 rent and we moved down to
a $600 rent right you know kind of thing
today in today's dollars it was a lot
less than that and back when the
dinosaurs roam the Earth but yeah but oh
my gosh wow I did the exact same crap no
I get it but I wanted something nice and
I had a job and I'd gotten out of
college and I'm I deserved it a lot of
23 year olds that are in a very similar
situation to Tanner now just think about
this if he gets a roommate and now he's
saving let's just call it $1,000 a month
okay splitting the rent he's paying off
that student loan debt of $77,000 really
really fast and now he's just stacking
money that's cash stacking cash man so
much
the housing market isn't known for being
easy to predict that's why it pays to
have a pro in your corner who's earned
the ramsy trusted Shield Ramsey trusted
real estate agents are the top experts
in their areas plus they have experiened
navigating a changing market so don't
step into the ring alone find a real
estate agent you can trust at ramseys
solutions.com SL agent or click in the
show notes Debbie is with us in Detroit
hi Debbie welcome to the ramsy
show hi thanks for taking my call sure
what's up um my husband and I made a
huge mistake we moved into a house about
uh two months ago and with the housing
market being so crazy and lots of
competition for homes we made a mistake
of buying a house for more than we
wanted to spend um we paid over list and
appraisal and we're now in a house that
um we just feel like we can't afford the
mortgage payment um it also has a pool
that is much more of an expense than we
thought it would be the house um needs a
lot of repairs and some things have come
up in the last couple of months that we
didn't realize were going to need to be
repaired right away um so my question is
should we plan on selling it or stay for
at least two years um and then not have
to worry about capital gains but if we
sell it now um we would probably walk
away with you know losing about 40
Grand there is no capital gain when you
lose
money right but on the odd chance if we
if you broke even if you break even
there's no capital gain capital gain
would only occur if you made a profit
right so it doesn't sound like that's a
problem yeah
but if if we sold it for what we bought
it if we just broke even we'd probably
lose about 40
Grand with closing costs and
everything so what's your house
payment um well that's the other thing
too it's more than what we thought it
would be with um the property taxes are
going to be more than we had planned for
so with property taxes and insurance
it's about $2,300 a month and what's
your monthly take-home pay in your
household about 9,000 okay all
right well you're slightly above what we
would tell you but not a huge amount um
it doesn't sound like this your your
house payment's not 40% of your
take-home
pay um this sounds more emotional than
mathematical okay just we feel like
we've been bleeding money ever since we
moved into the house because of the pool
and the repairs that have been needed
and what have you spent on repairs I'm
sorry what have you spent on
repairs um well with the pool it's
been uh over $1,000 um with the repair
we just had a garage door repaired that
was over 700 we need what' you pay for
the
house um we paid 410 for
it and you had $1,500 worth of repairs
and you're
panicking yeah well you make 100 you
make $140,000 a
year yeah well yeah yeah this is
emotional it doesn't sound like you're
bleeding out it feels like you got a
little scrape on the knee but it's just
a lot it sounds like it's more stress of
just we're having to I think you were
super impulsive and you did something
that you wish you hadn't done and that's
what's killing you the Math's not
killing you okay I mean we should it's
not
ideal uh but um I I probably would just
breathe a little bit here um okay you
know I I okay here here's the thing the
house payments not out of control the
repairs are not
$28,000 in one month they were 1,400 in
one month and you make 140 there's
nothing here that's causing red Sirens
to go off and fireworks and panic in the
numbers okay now I understand you have a
deep sense of regret because you feel
like you impulsed and overpaid uh but so
I don't want to trade $1,400 repair and
a house payment that's slightly over the
margins we teach which are conservative
for a
$440,000 loss right well the other thing
that I'm worried about too is um we
moved with our jobs because now we can
do our jobs from anywhere after coid and
there is a chance that my salary could
be decreased based on where we're living
now well if that happens and you can't
afford the house we can talk about
selling it then but we don't sell a
house on what might happen the house
might get hit by a tornado too yeah but
we're not going to sell it because it
might right Debbie do you guys have any
other debt other than this
mortgage uh we do have a car payment um
we owe about 12 Grand on a car we only
have one car and then we um just from
the move we've got about 6,000 on credit
cards so it sounds like there's some
other pieces to this puzzle that are
causing this stress do you have an
emergency
fund um we have about 25,000 in savings
okay right now I would write a check and
pay off the credit card and cut it up
and pay off the car a day right okay and
you guys need to get on a budget you are
not in control with your spending
today's question comes from Jimmy in
Kentucky my wife and I are on baby step
three and would love to buy a home but
we're nowhere near able to put down
money on a house we are concerned that
the market will continue to increase
before we can get a down payment saved
up can we use my VA loan to take
advantage of the 0% payment down payment
to get into a house sooner and refinance
in three to five
years Jimmy I'm going to say
no I mean VA loans they're just it's
just not it's not a great option I mean
there's so much with the fees everything
that that that is in that uh it makes it
a difficult it's a difficult mortgage
and between FHA VA and conventional it's
the most expensive unless you are
disabled if you're a fully disabled
veteran then they wave a lot of the fees
and stuff but it is not it's not a good
deal for you and basically what you're
doing is you're trying to find a way to
game the system you know you want to
scam the system and the system isn't
broke and it means delayed pleasure and
yes house prices are going to continue
to go up they're not going to continue
to go up like they have been the market
has slowed down substantially that is
not going to price you out of the market
Jimmy what will price you out of the
market is doing it dumb and moving into
something when you're broke and you have
no down payment and you're not ready to
buy you're going to get in a problem
you're you know that the the you know
you're going to create friction here in
your life it's not going to be fun and
you're going to turn we want you to have
a house we don't want the house to have
you yeah and that's what ends up
happening so much we talked about it on
the show yesterday with George that you
know your home it's such an emotional
thing right it's like where your family
is it's where you sleep at night it's
where you do your meals I mean like it
is it's such an emotional part of your
life and so many people rush into that
so it's it's an emotional part of your
life and it's the most expensive part of
your life it's usually the largest
purchase you ever make and so because of
that it's like you people make not wise
decisions when it comes to their money
with their houses because they just let
their emotions get ahead of them whether
it's fear whether it's long for
something plus there's all these stupid
people that are around you telling you
all the time to buy something you got to
buy house you got to buy house you got
to buy house you got to buy house you
can't be a renter you got to buy house
every oh God oh God oh God you're going
to get priced out okay okay and you know
what is your Beautician and Economist
the lady doing your NE Nails is not an
economist oh my God you know so stop
listening to these broke people with
their craziness uh because I've heard
that for 30 years yeah for 30 years I've
heard I'm going to get priced out of the
market and I can tell you real estate's
considerably more expensive than when I
started the show 30 years ago but but
you know and it'll be more expensive 30
years from now when you're still doing
the show so but the uh uh God willing
the Greek don't rush but the you oh my
gosh the uh uh that's but there's a lot
of outside pressure family members and
everybody else oh you had bought a house
yet you've been married 26 seconds and
you had bought a house oh my God and
there's all this craziness out there
well that and then on top of all the
emotion of just the recent yeah real EST
I mean all of it right so it's it's it's
I don't know there's a lot going on 2020
was one of the highest increases in
house prices in history yeah of all time
I mean in in modern history and 29% it
went up oh my that's unbelievable
unprecedented as they say in the coid
language but yeah oh my gosh yeah that's
just crazy and so uh it scares a cred
out of you but it's not it's not that's
not going to be what happens going
forward it's also not going to crash for
those of you waiting on the prices to go
down well let me but let's talk about
this because I've been there's there's
been so much I feel like even in the
recent probably like week or two about
the real estate market because there's I
read an article this morning the Seven
Cities where it continues to increase
substantially right so there was so I
read that and then There Are Places
though that they're seeing you're seeing
prices go down go down and so the
important thing there is to remember
that that still buyers or I'm sorry
sellers some of them are still in the
mindset of oh I can make yeah so much
they're still looking for a sucker
coming from another city so when you're
seeing those prices I just want to know
your thoughts on it is it going back to
just true home value of what the what
the house is really worth versus the
inflated prices yeah and so when when do
you know what your house is valued at
like a true value after all the
craziness of it going up so fast is it
that you can you still run comps like do
you know what I mean because going up so
fast is a reality okay so the definition
of market value for Real Estate when I
was in appraisal class y a thousand
years ago is still in college is still
the definition and every real estate
test you ever take to get your real
estate license is when a willing buyer
meets a willing seller and neither are
under
duress okay Webster I'm going to call
youster well I mean so here's the deal
so you have a buyer and a seller and
neither one of them are freaking out
okay the seller is not motivated by a
divorce or a bankruptcy or something
else okay okay the buyer is not over
motivated because the last three houses
they put offers in they didn't get and
so the marketplace is so white hot that
the buyer is under duress and so some of
these buyers were paying above market
value but their purchase does not enter
into an appraisal that that property is
not an actual indicator of value okay
because the one of the parties was under
duress yes you can't use a okay a
foreclosure on your street does not
affect the value of your house because
one of the parties was under duress okay
so that's not a value that's a price how
are you so how people out there that are
wanting to buy or like how do you run
comps now because I'm like usually you
just run comps if you run you run comps
and if one of them sticks up and shows
they all are going to stick up right
maybe maybe I mean if you if everybody
was a white hot buyer in the whole area
then the value probably has gone up yeah
because the marketplace was iness in
that sense but if you got some one-offs
like you know we we talked about during
the thing I live in a neighborhood where
uh like like almost all the houses that
sold in it's a nice neighborhood uh sold
recently were California people moving
in with California equity and the
Tennessee people are sitting there going
I got I got a sucker on the hook here
yeah they're going to way overpay
because they can't get a house there's a
shortage and so they're going to they're
over paying
substantially overvalue and and so
enough of that happens then other people
get greedy and they're like I didn't
really want to sell my house but if I
could sell it for that I'd sell it what
the heck and and one of the guys I was
playing golf with we talked about that
during the streaming thing that we doing
he goes I put mine on the market I put
an extra 200,000 bucks on it looking for
one of those California sucker fish I'm
GNA hook me one you know and it didn't
sell yeah and he said I haven't been
able to hook one so the market has
calmed down the market has calmed down
and the migration from California or New
York or wherever into these other uh
markets you know Southeastern markets
primarily is slowed down y but we've had
a million plus people displaced from
just California and New York yeah just
those two states moved out into other
markets and that it adversely affect
what is a real value but real value
should be based on a calm reasonable
wise transaction by both parties yes and
even that goes up 3 to 5% a
year remember folks you never want to
let the housing market control your
housing decisions only your personal
situation and finances should do that if
you're prepared to buy or sell a home
then it's a good time to do it even if
the market is changing if you're not
prepared then it's not a good time even
if the market looks favorable and if
that's the case it'll be worth the wait
to get in a better financial position to
do things the right way Trust me thanks
for listening make sure to share this
with the people in your life that are
getting hung up on what's happening in
the market and tune in to the next
episode where we really get tactical
about the steps it takes to purchase
your next
home